Hi, I'm Dr. Kevin Cutters, and this video is to invite you to my practitioner, Dr. Oli Newsletter series.
I decided to do this series because a friend of mine said to me a while ago that,
you know, if you pass away all the information that you have passes away with you, you need to share it with other people.
I used to give seminars, and that was very draining.
So I decided, well, why don't I just put it together a Newsletter series and then allow doctors to contact me if they need any extra help to share my knowledge with other people.
Though I realize that there's a lot of doctors out there that know a whole lot more than I do, but there's probably not very many that practice the way I do.
I graduated in 1986 from Northwestern car practice, thinking I was going to practice car practice the rest of my life. That was my passion.
Well, God has a way to change your mind and change your purpose.
We left car practice and went into full-time ministry doing some work done in Mexico for a period of time.
Then came back to car practice, thinking, well, this is what I'm going to do again.
And that's just not how it works out sometimes.
God said, patient, my way, actually, a car practice patient who said that she had breast cancer and that I was her only hope to help her from a nutritional standpoint because she chose not to do the chemo and radiation.
I was like, well, this is beyond my school of practice. I don't know what you're asking me to do here.
But that's when I started really digging into some nutritional, natural, integrative approaches to help these people that are very sick.
And one thing you led to another were actually 100 things, led to 100 things.
And I ended up leaving my car practice license and I only see cancer and lying patients helping them completely at an integrative level.
That is a substitute for their current care, but as an addition.
And I get doctors that call me on a weekly basis wanting help with patients.
So I thought, well, let's put this together in a newsletter format so that I can share tidbits of information that you might help you in practice.
Even if you have a pretty straight car practice, knowing some nutritional things or at least being able to steer people in a direction that could help them, I think is a wonderful thing that you could do.
So understand signing up for this, you get a newsletter about every week or two weeks.
I've never selling anything, so you don't have to worry about that.
I don't have a practice bandage with Ferb. I don't have seminar. There's nothing to buy.
So if you don't like it, unsubscribe. But if it's a blessing to you, then that's the whole idea.
So I invite you to sign up and check them out and tell a friend and hopefully we can help everybody.
So enjoy and I hope it's a blessing.